cleopatra leads the egyptian civ in sid
meier's civilization 6 Cleopatra is
famous not only for rising to power in
Egypt but for her famous affairs with
both Julius Caesar and Mark Antony
believed to have changed the course of
history in both Egypt and Rome the
Egyptian sibs special ability is called
ataru it allows Egypt to build districts
and wonders faster if they're located on
rivers flood plains do not block the
placement of districts and wonders
Cleopatra gives Egypt improvements to
trade routes external trade routes from
Egypt give Egypt additional gold trade
routes from other sibs give Egypt
additional gold as well and food for the
originator this makes Egypt and
attractive trading partner and a
valuable ally Egypt's unique unit is the
Mariano chariot Archer which gets bonus
movement when it starts on open terrain
early in the game it is best at fast
attacks its mobility means it can
respond to wide ranged threats Egypt
also gets the Sphinx as a unique tile
improvement sphinxes provide faith and
culture and get bonuses when built
adjacent to a wonder the Egyptians are a
wonderful sieve and especially powerful
in the early game when they start near a
river they're also uniquely valuable
partners to other sibs so rather than
isolating themselves the Egyptians
remains central to the political
landscape throughout the game take
control of the Egyptians from the cradle
of civilization in sid meier's
civilization 6
you